we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P you know one thing I've
learned in doing this show homophobic
people don't like being called
homophobic take a listen to this
hi David I'm calling from Decatur
Georgia
you know I watch this show regularly and
um anytime someone doesn't agree with
the
homosexual lesbian
transgender lifestyle you call them
transphobic
homophobic and I think that's wrong
people have a right to their own beliefs
and I think you should stop labeling
people as having a phobia
because they disagree with their
lifestyle
you should probably check yourself out
on that thank you listen the mere use of
the word lifestyle is already
problematic homophobes that I've been
interviewing for more than a decade love
to talk about the gay lifestyle and that
is a flag that you are homophobic now I
think it's important to understand that
when we use the term homophobic and
transphobic a lot of people like to play
the kind of literal semantic games where
they go it's not a phobia I just think
it's wrong this is similar to when
people when they hear the phrase
anti-Semitism they go why is the word
anti-Semitism semites also include
people of Arab descent not just Jews
right but Google the term anti-Semitism
the term anti-Semitism even though the
etymology relates to Semite is related
specifically to anti-jewish sentiment
and similarly when we talk about
homophobia and transphobia we don't
literally mean I'm a afraid it's a
phobia it is more all-encompassing than
that so not a shock homophobes and
transphobes don't like to be called that
we're going to have a fantastic bonus
show today we'll talk about the FTX
collapse we will talk about lab-grown
meat being cleared for human consumption
and we will talk about over a billion
young people being at risk for hearing
loss something that I have much to say
about sign up at joinpakman.com don't
miss today's bonus show